I I will now take the declaration for
whole West and hessel I in Anderson
being the acting returning officer for
the parliamentary election for Kingston
upon Hull West and hassle do hereby give
notice the number of votes recorded for
each candidate is as follows
do Bri Michelle Louise Fay independence
1898 Hardy Emma and Labour Party 18,000
eight eighteen thousand three hundred
and forty two lamb Eamonn Michael John
the green party 332 McKay christineanne
the Conservative Party ten thousand
three hundred and seventeen shores Gary
Colley UK Independence Party
1399 Taylor William Anthony the
Libertarian Party 67 Thomas Claire
Liberal Democrats 2210 the there were 48
spoilt ballot papers and the turnout was
57 point five percent and I do therefore
hereby declare that Emma and Hardy is
duly elected member of parliament for
Hull Wessel
[Applause]
thank you just like to start by thanking
all their staff and everybody who have
been involved in the count and all the
people that have been in there counting
four hours it's absolutely incredible
that they managed to do it so quickly of
course I'd like to thank my agent but
also particularly like to thank Tracy
for being an incredible incredible
Calloway you have you have been so
brilliant and to all of the Labor Party
campaign as an activist you've got
involved and become part of this and it
is it's a movement and it's a movement
for hope this triumph in whole Western
Hazel is a triumph of Hope over hate
because that's what we're seeing here
and that is why we've had so many people
involved in this campaign that is why
we've had so many volunteers because
people want to see that change because
they've sick and tired of what's
happening this government and they're
ready for that change and I promise you
I will not let you down and I will go
down there and deliver that for you
thank you very much
[Applause]